Southern lebanon's border towns largely
abandoned and
devastated an escalating conflict
between Israel and the Lebanese armed
group Hezbollah has created a deao
buffer zone along the border several
kilometers
deep Israel has floated the idea of
formalizing the buffer zone saying it
will restore security but Hezbollah says
it won't pull
back instead it to started targeting
largely evacuated towns to make Northern
Israel
uninhabitable is Israel is trying to
show it has options to help settlers
return to the North in a safe way and to
keep Hezbollah and the resistance away
from the south it doesn't it must stop
its war on Gaza and
Lebanon Israel has increased the
intensity of its strikes on what it says
is hezbollah's military
infrastructure in one of the biggest
attacks it repeatedly hit a strategic
Valley known to be the Lebanese armed
group's main area of operations and a
gateway to the country's interior the
Israelis appear to also be trying to
degrade the infrastructure the kind of
the the the capabilities and depths that
hasb has why because I think and this is
true for both sides that there is at
least an expectation or they are
preparing which would be smart for a
much wider and open Conflict for now
Hezbollah is not using its full military
capabilities in what some describe as a
balancing act and there are those who
believe Israel is not in a position to
start a wider conflict as the Gaza War
rages so for the moment Israel doesn't
have really any strategy but to keep
responding to hezbollah's attack and
create kind of a balance between the
hisbah attack without going any further
because it doesn't have a plan or the
capability the Israeli military has said
a lot still needs to be done to return
residents home Israel's strategy may be
to use targeted escalation to pressure
Hezbollah but the group says this front
will remain active until Israel's war on
Gaza ends and while it is unlikely to
trigger a large War it says it is ready
to fight Without Limits if War breaks
out an allout War may not be eminent but
even though the combat is still largely
limited to the border and to military
Targets this is very much a War Z alaz
Southern
Lebanon make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer